[Music]
[Applause]
well look jacob
we're at the shelter it's got a little
bit of a saggy bit
well welcome back to another episode of
the outdoor boys youtube channel for
those of you who follow my channel
you'll recognize
this shelter me and my oldest son thomas
we spent
eight days camping and building this
shelter by hand
and uh i want to finish it off so that's
what we're going to do today
and i've got my youngest son jacob with
me
well it's january and it's a lot colder
than it was last time i was here at the
shelter
um i definitely want to do some
improvements to make this place a little
bit
warmer a little bit more pleasant and
it's going to take more than one day to
do
everything i have in mind so we better
get cracking
but oh you are stinky now in the last
video i told you that the bow saw i was
using
was getting a little bit beat up so i
went and bought another
bow saw this is uh made by agawa and
it assembles a lot quicker and easier
than the other one but it goes something
like
that and there you go
[Applause]
daddy this one
[Music]
hey
let's go find a big dead straight tree
that we can use
here we go
hey
[Music]
hmm
hey jacob do you want to build the fire
yeah so let's get some firewood
i'm going to chop up a bunch of firewood
so
okay yeah [ __ ] fella
you're not going to clean myself got
swell
now fire feels good
for dinner tonight we're gonna be eating
peruvian style rotisserie chicken
i even made up a bottle of aji verde
sauce this is cilantro
jalapeno mayonnaise mustard and a few
other seasonings
and that's going to go on our chicken
and our french fries oh yes
we're making french fries too
you ready for daddy to make some dinner
yeah
uh
[Applause]
there you go we got some green sauce on
the side it smells amazing
there you go
i'm gonna polish this off with my
favorite drink ever hawaiian sun
lilly koi strawberry
oh that's good look what i got flood
yeah i love fly
jake are you having fun camping
i think i might have to start working on
breakfast here in a little bit
good morning jacob hey did you sleep
well
are you hungry yeah
you like bacon it's an unwritten rule of
father-son camping that when little boys
wake up their dad should have a fire
and breakfast ready for him you know
keeping little kids warm is a real
challenge in the winter so you can see
what i've done
is i've taken tommy and nathan's
sleeping bags and stuffed one inside the
other
and did that keep you warm last night
yeah there
well first on today's agenda is
finishing the roof and to do that i'm
gonna need four to six
long thin saplings
well it's actually nice and warm out so
i think we should go get some mud
and start doing some cheeking
that'll do yeah you can see right here
we're at the toe of a little bluff
and all here is a flood plain so this is
where silt and clay is going to get
deposited when the river floods
let me help you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
alrighty i think we're done well it's
taking me five hours but i've got
the front and back of this wall
completely sealed up i used
one and a half buckets worth of mud it's
not too physically demanding and it
doesn't take all that much mud
it's just very very tedious well jacob
has been very patient while i've been
chinking this
wall we skipped lunch and so he just ate
some leftovers
i think i need to make him a good dinner
should we go get some firewood and make
dinner
all right guys i have a bubogee tinfoil
dinner here that we're going to cook up
now
in case you don't know bubogee is
marinated beef korean style
and i've got big piles of bubogia on top
of carrots
onions potatoes it's going to be pretty
awesome
look at this
is that good well the sun's about to set
here on our second day and
i think we're gonna go home you know
jake's only three years old and
he's done really great on this campout
but
i think it's time to go see mama you
want to see mama
[Music]
well it is a cold wet winter day and a
perfect reminder that we
need to do something about our heating
situation in that cabin
i want to be able to build a fire inside
without burning the place down so i am
going to make a wood stove
from this 55 gallon drum
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
oh there you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're going to get this thing
roaring we're gonna test this thing out
and we're gonna burn off as much paint
as we can
you can see all the smoke and those
greenish flames that's from the paint
catching on fire once we burn off all
the paint this thing shouldn't smoke as
much
there we go burned all the paint off all
right i got some of this rust-oleum high
heat spray paint meant for barbecues and
stuff
tommy's helping me spray-paint all this
[Music]
well the mud jinking on this wall has
been drying for two weeks and it looks
really good
and there's a few places where you can
see sunlight we should be able to plug
up those big cracks really easy
yeah this cheeky is going to work great
[Music]
well in case you're wondering yes i am
wearing a brace turns out i jacked up a
bunch of tendons and
muscles in my arm
i'm sure this is exactly what my doctor
meant when they said rest
all right let's see
okay none of the metals touching any of
the wood
so when i build a fire in that fireplace
that snow pipe's gonna get hot
and that tarp around it is gonna get hot
and melt
so i'm gonna build a little fire in
there and try to get the tarp to melt
back a bit
i'm gonna put some clay up in there and
we're going to see what happens
later on i'm going to build a better
stove jack to make a better seal
and a more safer roof but i just want to
get this for tonight so that we can be
warm
we got a pretty decent fire in there and
the tarp is melting a little bit but
very slowly which is what we want we
want a controlled
melt but uh it's pretty warm in here
isn't it guys
yeah yeah man it's like 27 degrees
outside
nathan's gone shirtless in here let's
get our sleeping bags and everything set
up okay
all right we need to get some dinner
going here you guys want some grilled
cheese sandwiches yeah
awesome
oh that's looking good who wants a
grilled cheese sandwich
perfect rosemary and olive oil bread
with
good sharp cheddar so i'm going to make
a whole bunch more so you guys eat up as
much as you want
that's a good girl i might need to take
my fleece off it's getting warm in here
you guys having a good time yeah pretty
good you want some dessert
yeah let me reach under here into my
cupboard
whoa
all right we're gonna turn off the
lights and i'll see you guys in the
morning
are you guys hungry all right i'll make
another pea breakfast
is a cinnamon raisin brioche loaf it's
kind of like a cinnamon roll without the
frosting the eggs are kind of frozen
that's icing the eggs
they're so frozen it's like an egg
[Music]
slushy
here guys you want some french toast
yeah do you guys like that is that good
well it is a cold beautiful day here and
i was planning
on doing more chinking and taking that
mud and shoving into the rest of the
cracks
but the mud's frozen and so i have to
thaw it out piece by piece to get that
done
and i don't want to do that so i want to
get the roof really secured
and i also want to get lots of firewood
okay
uh
there we go got a little bit of firewood
for our next couple trips
ready for some delicious steak
peppermint
the butter put it in the bag there take
a thing of rosemary
put it in there all right we're gonna
take these steaks and we're gonna put
them inside the cooler
pour that hot water right there leave
the cooler right there for a couple
hours it'll add a little water to it as
it cools down
so if you're into steaks you'll
recognize what i'm doing as a technique
called sous-vide
i'm soaking the steaks in hot water and
it's cooking
the steak and then after they've spent
about two three hours
in this hot water bath i'll pull them
out and caramelize them
over a really high heat well i want my
backpacking tarp back so
while the steaks are soaking the
sous-vide bath i'm gonna go ahead and
take it off the roof and replace it
with one of these contractor tarps
all right well we got the new roof on
let's check out those stakes and get
those frying up
there we go
all right who wants some steak guys
yeah well we got a lot done
but my arm is killing me i gotta go home
and ice some joints
over here bud
oh there she is ah
yeah looking good in here well we're
gonna get the camp set up
i'm gonna get a fire going i'm gonna
start working on a door
a little milk got a warm fire not too
bad huh
all right jake if we're gonna make a
door i need a long straight tree that's
about four inches in diameter
[Music]
alrighty
[Laughter]
well we've made some good progress but
time has really gotten away from me it's
already past five o'clock the sun's
gonna set in less than half an hour
and my right arm is dead i have done bad
things to it but i'm gonna soak up the
fire gonna get some food cooking and
me and jacob just gonna have a good time
you want some hamburgers today
[Music]
all right so i forgot all the lettuce
and tomatoes and onions and everything
but that's okay it's still delicious
isn't it jacob
yeah well me and jacob have full bellies
and a warm fire we're gonna snuggle up
here
watch some cartoons and i'll see you
guys in the morning
it was nice and toasty in here kept the
fire going all night long and it was
so warm i end up taking my sweater off
and all my hand warmers off
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
it's really smooth and surprisingly
square considering
let's see what it's like inside
a little bit of a breeze is kicked up
and the door makes all the difference
oh man this is perfect i am so pleased
with this
i need to put a latch on it i need to
put a handle on it i need to put a
little more trim
and make it a little bit more airtight
but i am super pleased but it's a good
stopping point
i think it's time to go home my thumbs
have been smashed so many times with
that axe
and my right arm is just killing me
i think it's time to play in the mud
what do you think
[Music]
yeah is that a good mud snake you think
[Applause]
[Music]
i've done all the chinking around the
fireplace and my fingers are cold and i
am very
hungry so we're gonna get a fire started
make some lunch
and uh warm up a little bit
all right
i have done something to my back oh i
think i might need to go home and take
it easy
i don't want to seize up out here with
jacob
it's a good thing i got out of there
when i did because my back
seized up as soon as i got home and i
have been
laid out for two days now but on the
upside
my elbow feels a lot better so you know
there's that
well for the first time in two days i'm
on my feet but i
should go lay down some more
not sure it's a good idea but i'm on my
feet
and i'm back here at the cabin and uh
we're gonna see if we can't get some
work done
well i'm gonna try to take it easy today
so one of the things i'm gonna do is go
check a bunch of motion activated game
cameras i set up
before we went on our trip to alaska
last month you want to go check the
cameras
there's some deer in the water
oh whoa
and he
need one
well i've spent another five hours
chinking today and we got a lot done but
it's time to make some dinner you hungry
yeah
all right
holy mackerel it is warm in there that
chinking is making a huge difference
[Applause]
we've got cupcakes for dessert you like
your cupcake
it is so warm and cozy in here i might
have to sleep with my sleeping bag
unzipped
i'm gonna go to bed and i will see you
guys in the morning
you want some sausage buddy yeah
should we have cupcakes for breakfast
[Music]
[Music]
well i finished all the cheeking inside
the cabin and it only took me 18 hours
and one back injury so there you go this
looks
pretty good i want a latch
okay all right
there we go okay
a bit fidgety but there you go got a
door latch
nice and tight and uh not a lot of air
coming in through there
oh no it's a jacob zombie
one little problem we got to deal with
is this big dead tree right here i don't
want that thing falling on my shelter so
we're gonna take it out
when you drop a tree you cut a notch and
then you saw the back side
and it falls in towards the notch
however this one's
really rotten over here and while i was
sawing
it started pinching my blade which means
it's falling this way
i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to try to notch it on this left
side to get it to fall that way
that was all sorts of sketchy i didn't
drop it where i was aiming
but i didn't drop it on the cabin so
oh i had some grand aspirations about
cutting this all up into firewood today
but technically i'm supposed to be
resting my back and arm i think i better
call for today
i'm just really thrilled with how this
log cabin's turned out and the more i
work on it the more plans and ideas i
come up with i think i might want to
make some whitewash and whitewash the
outside of it to make it last longer
i want to put some shelves inside and i
got to build that latrine
but that's all i think i'm going to do
for this video i got to rest my back and
arm for a week or two
but if you guys want to see the initial
building of this i'll put a link in the
description to the first video in this
series and if you guys want to see what
i do next make sure to click subscribe
i put out new videos every saturday
morning thanks for watching guys
have a great day if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
i missed you too